hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger est fiché oui tu veux du
bordel quoi ah si tu leur dis venez en
fait fait déborder la corse est mal que
c'est mal c'est mal je n'allais juge
voulait dire quelque chose et on va
accueillir dans un instant juste manqué
non parce qu'ils sont rigoler il ya
quelqu'un je sais qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
revient de cannes et chantal bonjour
ça ne va pas du tout aller de l'avant et
on s'arrête
non
une équipe jeune anton et qui n'avait
pas bu l'eau merci est-ce qu'on va
ok ok on arrête tout là bas alors on
arrête tout on accueille tout de suite
on accueille tout de suite camille cobbi